willkommen bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
40 Stunden jede Woche frühs Aufstehen
Überstunden noch oben drauf und am Ende
des Monats kaum mehr auf der Hand als
der der keinen Job hat der vom
Sozialstaat lebt künftig dann vom neuen
Bürgergeld wo lohnt sich wirklich noch
zu arbeiten die richtigen Fragen jetzt
an diese Gäste nämlich an Martin Schilde
waren den Chef der links Partei und
Mitglied des Europaparlaments Uwe Hück
gelernter Maler und Lackierer er hat
sich durchgeboxt hochgeboxt kann man
sagen im Berufsleben bis zum mächtigen
betriebsratsboss bei Porsche Michael
klammt ist bei uns er lebt gut auch ohne
Arbeit nennt sich selbst den faulsten
deutschen Thomas im Stein ist bei uns
Musikmanager sie kennen ihn vor allem
von Deutschland sucht den Superstar wo
er Karrieren gemacht und Karrieren
verhindert hat und zugeschaltet Ralf
Stegner Bundestagsabgeordneter der SPD
die mit ihrem Bürgergeld heute im
Bundesrat vorübergehend oder erstmal
gestoppt worden ist herzlich willkommen
an diese Runde lohnt sich es ihre
Auffassung noch in Deutschland zu
arbeiten
nun Sektor sagen die ganz offen warum
muss ich noch arbeiten gehen wenn es
können Sie einfach mal feststellen 2.400
Euro brutto ca 800 Euro Abgaben da
bleibt nicht mehr viel übrig deshalb
wäre mir lieber gewesen wir Ampel hätte
Steuersystem reformiert das brauchen wir
Bürokratiemonster aber da glaube ich ist
auch die anderen Parteien haben einfach
die Eier nicht dazu das zu verändern ich
bin selber Unternehmer wir brauchen
dringend Reformen im Unternehmen und wir
brauchen keine Geschenke mit Geschenke
kommen wir nicht weiter die Menschen für
die sich das Arbeiten nicht mehr oder
kaum noch lohnt das ist zum Beispiel
luigi-annone den kennen sie den Mann aus
Pforzheim zeigen wir Ihnen einmal ganz
kurz im Bild das ist der Mann ähnliche
Frisur wie sie was macht der
der ist unter anderem auch in
Industriegebiet also der macht zum
Beispiel Handwerker in Handwerker Beruf
der ist überall aber die ist bei mir
Trainer im Fußballverein ist eigentlich
ein Mädchen für alles und er ist sehr
anständig und er war eins wird er nie
machen er wird niemals auf der Tasche
vom Staat liegen aber er sagte auch ist
du mich nicht motivieren mit der sagt
nämlich genau das sie haben ihn uns
einmal mitgebracht sozusagen aus
Pforzheim und das ist was er aktuell zum
Bürgergeld sagt
Hartz IV war ja schon eigentlich
gut genug für die Leute und jetzt noch
das Bürgergeld also dann stell ich mir
die Frage als Geringverdiener für was
soll ich da noch arbeiten gehen ehrlich
gesagt ne weil wenn ich mir dann
überlege dann gibt es Leute wo zu Hause
sitzen und
mehr verdienen oder mehr bekommen
in puncto Geld wie ich
wofür soll ich dann noch arbeiten fragte
er sich in Pforzheim Herr Stegner machen
Sie es im Moment mit ihrem
bürgergeldplan Menschen wie ihm zu
leicht nicht mehr zu arbeiten
nein überhaupt nicht und ich hat kann
auch nichts daran finden dass die Lösung
daran liegen soll dass die die wenig
verdienen ausgespielt werden gegen die
die noch weniger haben sondern der Kern
liegt woanders dass wir den
Niedriglohnsektor abschaffen indem wir
fahren vernünftige Tariflöhne bezahlen
alle Änderungen übrigens die wir da
machen Mindestlohn hoch Verbesserung für
Familien mit geringen Einkommen die
werden hier von denjenigen bekämpft die
hier große Sprüche machen über die Frage
wir sollten das mit dem Bürgergeld nicht
tun es geht nicht darum jemanden zu
helfen der nicht arbeiten will sondern
wir müssen den Leuten helfen den ich
arbeiten können und müssen was dafür tun
es in den Arbeitsmarkt kommen aber vor
allen Dingen müssen ordentliche
Tariflöhne bezahlt werden und ich bin
dabei was gesagt haben mit dem
Steuersystem das Problem ist nur die
Veränderung in die Richtung zu gehen
dass die mit den höchsten Einkommen und
Vermögen mehr beitragen müssen das
werden die Veränderungen im Steuersystem
sinnvoll wären und dass diejenigen die
hart arbeiten müssen mehr davon haben
das ist der Wunsch den wir durchaus
teilen aber was dazu glauben die Lösung
liegen einfach nein entsteht man so tut
als ob diejenigen die nicht arbeiten
nicht arbeiten wollen das ist ein Irrtum
ist ein ganz kleiner Prozentsatz von dem
das aber wahrscheinlich wird luigianone
bei seinem Arbeitgeber schon mal nach
mehr Lohn gefragt haben und der wird im
Moment sagen geht nicht schaffen wir
nicht und dann dann zahlen Sie im Moment
seinem Nachbarn der nicht arbeiten geht
im Moment ein hohes Bürgergeld und
luigianone sitzt da und wir haben es ja
gerade gehört und schaut sich das an und
sagt also dafür morgens aufstehen weiß
nicht
also entschuldige mal entschuldigen sie
mal aber von wegen geht nicht ist das
kann man nicht so sagen der Staat hat
mit enormen Mittel mit dem
Kurzarbeitergeld die den Firmen geholfen
durch die corona-krise zu kommen und
auch jetzt die von Lohnkosten entlastet
auch den Arbeitnehmern geholfen zu sein
geht nicht das ist kein Argument und
noch mal jemand der sozial Transfers
bekommt soll nicht mehr haben und das
ist auch nicht der Fall wenn
Arbeitnehmer die sehr geringe Einkommen
haben kriegen auch Wohngeld und andere
Dinge da müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
dies dann auch in Anspruch nehmen aber
die Lösung liegt nicht darin die zu
bekämpfen den wir helfen müssen
rauszukommen und ich will dir mal eine
Zahl nennen die sie das Gut
unterstreicht wir es wird geschätzt dass
es ungefähr 60 Millionen Euro gibt die
ausgegeben werden jährlich dafür Leute
die zu Unrecht Hartz IV bekommen wir
reden aber über 100 Milliarden ungefähr
die durch Steuerhinterziehung und
dadurch dass Leute die das können ihre
Steuer nicht bezahlen sind
am Ruder sie haben den Finanzminister
gestellt Herr sie sind selber macht
Jemal
tun sie alles gegen Feuer hier fragen
müssen bei uns in der Runde Thomas
Unterstützung kennen auch Sie Herr
Stegner von Deutschland sucht den
Superstar unter anderem ist
erfolgreicher Musikmanager Unternehmer
wir schauen uns ja Stein mal gemeinsam
die neuen bürgergeldsätze an so wie sie
kommen sollen also heute im Bundesrat ja
erstmal abgeschmettert aber Herr Stegner
wird alles dafür tun dass das Gesetz
doch noch so durchkommt doch noch die
Zustimmung der Ministerpräsidenten
findet also das sind sie die neuen Sätze
vom Bürgergeld unten der Balken jeweils
der Hartz iv-salz und oben das gelbe
sind die Sätze im Bürgergeld also 5002
Euro im Monat für ein alleinstehenden
das muss
jemand der arbeitet auch erstmal
verdienen Herrstein nach 5 vor 2 Euro
ist ja nur die halbe Wahrheit es kommt
ja noch dazu dass die Miete gezahlt wird
dass der Strom gezahlt wird und viele
anderen Sozialleistungen
die Heizung hat so dass also hier ein
bisschen anders sich darstellt und dann
komme ich zu der Rechnung der Huckarde
gemacht hat wenn du 2200 hast und es
runter rechnest dann kommst Du sehr nah
an die Grenze mit nichts tun eigentlich
in der Lage bist auch ein einkömmliches
Auskommen zu haben und das wird und bin
ich immer höre die Steuern muss
Steuerreform machen warum macht sie
keiner das höre ich seit ungefähr 20
Jahren wir müssen Steuerreform machen
können Sie verstehen waren als linken
Chef dass sich im Moment ganz viele in
Deutschland die haben bisschen veräppelt
fühlen die jeden Morgen eben Aufstehen
die hart arbeiten gehen die Überstunden
machen und die dann ja vielleicht wie
Herr Stegner sagt noch einen Ticken mehr
haben als die die nicht arbeiten aber
eben nur noch ganz wenig mehr und vor
allen Dingen die Energiekosten auch noch
abdrücken müssen na klar kann ich
verstehen dass die Leute die sich
morgens aus dem Bett quälen und dann
harten Tag die vor sich haben ärgern
darüber dass andere die viel weniger
sozusagen tun zum Beispiel die
Superreichen in diesem Land die einfach
von dem Erbe ihrer Eltern oder den
Familien aus denen sie stammen leben
dann einen guten Tag verbringen aber das
Kernproblem ist doch wirklich das dass
wir viel zu niedrige Löhne in
Deutschland haben dass der Ärger genau
darauf schon seit Jahren in diesem Land
existiert ohne dass etwas passiert ist
in diesem Bereich wir hatten lohnt
Zurückhaltung über lange Jahre über
lange Jahrzehnte hinweg dadurch sind die
Löhne in Deutschland nicht entsprechend
zum Beispiel im Vergleich zu anderen
europäischen Ländern gestiegen und das
hat sich natürlich ausgewirkt darauf
dass wir einen riesigen
Niedriglohnsektor haben jeder fünfte
Deutsche Arbeit im Niedriglohnsektor das
ist ein Spitzenwert in Europa und das
hat was mit einer verfehlten Lohnpolitik
zu tun da müssen sich vor allem die
Arbeitgeber an die Nase fassen da muss
ich aber auch die Politik in der
Vergangenheit an die Nase lassen
Wirtschaftskrise wenn sie natürlich
jetzt den großen Wirtschaftsunternehmen
hier sitzt jemand von früher einem der
größten Automobil
System von Porsche nämlich wenn sie
Porsche im Moment sagen ihr müsst die
Löhne mal deutlich anheben was passiert
dann wir müssen gucken ganz einfach wir
müssen konkurrenzfähig sein Gegenüber
andere in Europa auf der Welt in China
etc wir müssen nur ein bisschen alle mal
auf dem Boden bleiben das Problem ist im
niedrigen Lohn gesektor nicht das Brutto
sondern das Netto ist das Problem die
Leute können da locker damit auskommen
es kann aber nicht sein dass der Staat
immer mehr Steuern verlangt gerade bei
den Menschen das geht nicht
lassen 400 Euro und dann nochmal 800
Euro Abgaben da bin ich mal dass die
aber wirklich
sagen mit Schloss Porsche doch höhere
Löhne zahlen würde das funktionieren
also könnte Porsche sein oder ist das
absolute
ist ja nicht Deutschland da gibt es noch
ganz andere der Mittelstand des Handwerk
davon ich bin jetzt zum Beispiel der das
Mittelstands da haben wir ein Problem
also das Brutto ist nicht das Problem
dass netto der Menschen ist das Problem
sie kriegen zu wenig raus und der Staat
muss den und die Unternehmer
unterstützen was der Staat macht die tun
ja die Großunternehmer unterstützen
nicht den Mittelstand nicht das Handwerk
und wir brauchen Menschen wieder die
motiviert sind wir haben keine Leute die
bereit sind ins Handwerk zu gehen in
Mittelstand zu gehen also Anreize müssen
wir machen wir müssen viele Anreize
machen dass sie reingehen ich tue durch
meine lernstiftung Menschen ins Handwerk
hineinbringen komm mal selber von vom
Handwerk aber da macht die Politik viel
viel zu wenig wir brauchen die
Unterstützung der Politik im Mittelstand
der schon lange nicht mehr arbeitet für
den das nicht erlebensinhalt ist Michael
klammt es bei uns der sich selbst den
faulsten deutschen nennt so darf ich das
sagen weil sich selber eben von sich
sagen seit wann arbeiten sie nicht mehr
ja ich arbeite natürlich also jetzt
überhaupt nicht mehr arbeiten tue ich
jetzt seit 2020 aber bei mir hat das
schon recht früh angefangen und das ist
vielleicht auch der Unterschied zwischen
den Herren hier am Tisch ja der alle
eine Karriere gemacht haben ich wollte
das nicht ja also wenn sich vorstellen
mit 16 Jahren alle möchten tolles Abitur
machen was tolles lernen was tolles
lernen ich wollte das nicht ganz einfach
deshalb weil es mir meine Lebenszeit
wegnimmt ja ich hatte ich hatte keine
Motivation für eine Karriere meine
Lebenszeit zu opfern und jetzt bin er
habe ja schon gewisses Alter bin ich
sehr froh dass ich so gemacht habe denn
ich kann zurückschauen und kann sagen es
war ein tolles Leben es war eine
entspanntes Leben ein schönes Leben und
ich mache es nicht erst wenn es später
ist sie haben noch 10 Jahre wenn wir in
arbeitsbiografien denken was sie nicht
tun dann hätten sie noch zehn Jahre
Arbeit sozusagen vor sich sind 57 das
darf ich einmal sagen was machen Sie den
ganzen Tag ja das sind gute Frage
momentan bin ich ja gerade beim
Ordnungsamt und da kommen wir auch
gerade kurz zum Bürgergeld wenn ich das
kurz sagen darf wir reden ja über das
Bürgergeld aber wir müssen vielleicht
mal an diese Bürger denken denen das
total wird ja ich glaube wir ist einmal
noch mal ganz kurz bei ihr bleiben und
dann diskutieren wir auch mit ihm wir
wollen Sie einmal kennenlernen also was
wovon leben sie aktuell leben sie von
vom Sozialstaat nein ich lebe nicht von
sozialstadt ich habe früher im Tourismus
gearbeitet also ich war fünf Jahre auf
Kreuzfahrt ab sechs Weltreisen gemacht
es waren angenehme Jobs sozusagen sehr
angenehme Jobs habe ich auch für gesorgt
dass das angenehm ist sonst hätte ich es
nicht gemacht und ich war auch
rundreiseleiter in der Karibik ich
verfäre in der Karibik und da habe ich
ganz gut verdient und habe mir zwei
Wohnungen gekauft und von diesen zwei
Wohnungen von diesen Einnahmen lebe ich
jetzt also schon alleine von dem
Mieteinnahmen
keine Steuern weil es nicht weil es
verboten ist aber sondern weil ich genau
unter diesem Satz bin was man zahlen
müsste verstehen was geht Ihnen bei
einer solchen Biografie durch den Kopf
jemand der sagt für mich Arbeit ja
lebenszeitverschwendung ich komme
wunderbar so durch ich habe zwei
Mietwohnungen das passt naja wenn man
zwei Mietwohnung hat und sich alles
leisten kann ist es ja nicht ganz so
schlimm aber ich glaube dass das der
Vorbildcharakter der hier entsteht ist
meiner sie nicht zuträglich gerade für
junge Leute die ja eigentlich in ans
Reiz haben er sagt das ja auch immer wir
müssen wieder Anreize schaffen wir
müssen das muss ein Ruck durch die
Gesellschaft gehen dass du Spaß hast an
der Arbeit ich meine keine Arbeit macht
immer Spaß auch die das Politiker
möglicherweise macht immer Spaß aber es
ist so
meistens klar aber das ist doch so dass
wir wieder mal ein uns selber aus dem
Kragen herausziehen müssen aus dem
schlamasseln den wir hängen und das
können wir nicht nur über hohe Gehälter
ich glaube auch der Fußballer weil wir
ja bald wieder Fußball sprechen der
kriegt der läuft mit 10 Millionen Gehalt
nicht schneller als mit einer Million
Gehalt mach dir das ein bisschen
schlechtes Gewissen weil die Wahrheit
ist ja auch wenn wir das alle so machen
würden wie sie
da bin ich leider anderer Meinung und
ich glaube auch die Tendenzen in der
Gesellschaft zeigen das ist auch so sein
wird und diese Tendenzen werden viel
gravierender sein als das Bürgergeld ja
es gibt eine vier Tage Woche das war so
Jugendliche alle weniger arbeiten ja die
Leute wollen weniger arbeiten die haben
keine Lust mehr herzustellen die eine
Karriere zu machen und alles für die
Karriere pack die Brötchen für Sie wer
backt das Brot für Sie wer macht die
Wurst für Sie wer kommt ins Haus um die
Handwerker arbeiten zu machen und und
und natürlich werden diese Arbeiten auch
gemacht aber wenn zum Beispiel Arbeiten
sind die nicht so toll sind die dürfen
dann vielleicht mehr bezahlt werden ja
aber es gibt natürlich man kann das
nicht globalisieren aber man kann es
nicht so für alle beschreiben es gibt ja
Leute die arbeiten gerne in ihrem Beruf
das sollen sie auch machen aber viele
und die Tendenz ist wirklich so dass
viele Leute nicht mehr arbeiten wollen
ja wir reden hier alle das war unbedingt
viel arbeiten müssen aber das stimmt
doch gar nicht
wir haben hier ist das der Fall Problem
in der Gastronomie wir haben ein Problem
mit angebliche Gesundheitswesen wir
haben ein Problem im Handwerk Leute das
Land lebt durch Arbeit und nicht
durchschlafen
Arbeits- und ausbildungsprobleme haben
wir auch weil das ist ja ein wichtiger
das ist ja ein wichtiger Punkt
Herr Stegner wir haben aktuell
1,8 Millionen offene Stellen in
Deutschland und wir haben gleichzeitig
über deutlich über zwei Millionen
Arbeitslose im Land gab schon viel
schlimmere Zeiten aber da einfache
Rechnung ist ne wenn jeder die offene
Stelle jeder der arbeitslos ist eine
offene Stelle annehmen könnte wäre das
Problem gelöst weil wie kann das sein
wie erklären sie das dass wir in so
einer Zeit so viel offene Stellen haben
die nicht zu besetzen sind
also jedenfalls liegt es nicht an dem
was eben gerade gesagt worden ist Leben
was der Herr da geführt hat das ist doch
eine Karikatur die meisten Leute würden
gerne arbeiten und manche kriegen keine
Chancen dafür vernünftig zu arbeiten wir
müssen was tun für Bildung dass Leute
nicht ohne Abschlüsse bleiben wir müssen
mit denen die zu uns kommen aus anderen
Ländern besser umgehen da geht die Ampel
jetzt ran weil das mit den konservativen
nicht zu machen war dass er uns um die
Ausbildung stärker kümmern müssen dass
wir diejenigen die zu uns kommen
arbeiten lassen und ihnen das nicht
teilweise untersagen die wir sind auch
ein Einwanderungsland das ist ein und
wir müssen die Arbeit anständig bezahlen
wir sollten bei Corona gelernt haben wo
die Arbeitsplätze ausgewandert sind in
den anderen Länder nach China und sonst
so hin wenn man glaubte mit Lohndumping
mehr Gewinne machen zu können und dann
haben wir die Produkte nicht mehr und
scheitern daran das andere die
Lieferketten nicht funktionieren wir
können nur über gut bezahlte Arbeit über
vernünftige Qualität von von
Dienstleistungen und und Arbeit und
anständigen Gründe was werden aber die
Erklärung
des Solidarität die machen die
Solidarität ist nicht bei denjenigen die
jetzt keine Lust haben zu arbeiten
solche gibt es auch aber das ist der
kleinste aller kleinste Teil der Grund
dafür dass wir so viel offene Stellen
haben das habe ich nicht verstanden was
ist dann der Grund dafür aus ihrer Sicht
ganz einfach keine müssen in Teilen was
für die Qualifikation tun oder nehmen
Sie mal den Pflegebereich also ein
Beispiel haben wir besonders viel Bedarf
die Arbeitsbedingungen sind aber nicht
so wie sie sein sollten dann machen
Leute Gewinne indem sie mit Leiharbeit
Zeitarbeit versuchen sozusagen Profite
zu machen in Wirklichkeit brauchen wir
aber Mindestverordnung wie viele Leute
da sein müssen aber Menschen fliehen
das liegt doch ein Stück weit auf der
Hand und der Stegner spricht jetzt über
den Pflegebereich das ist ja ein Bereich
in dem jetzt nicht alle sofort Hurra
schreien wo sie zuerst arbeiten wollen
da haben wir offene Stellen und wir
haben gleichzeitig über 2 Millionen
Arbeitslose könnte doch daran liegen
dass es sehr bequem ist dann manchmal
auch zu sagen na dann vielleicht doch
lieber Bürger Geld Entschuldigung also
ich denke dass dieser Job natürlich
viele keinen großen Anreiz biete weil du
nämlich in eine Dilemma damit der
Emotion auf der anderen Seite Empathie
kann es nicht lernen die hast du hast du
das heißt also wenn mein Pflegebereich
niemand findet nicht nur was mit Geld zu
tun sondern auch damit das in guter
schlechter Pfleger mit weniger oder
guter Pflege oder weniger Empathie auch
gerne ist das heißt in den Punkten dann
ist nicht arbeiten eben doch besser also
es ist nicht arbeiten aber wir müssen
wir müssen auch widersprechen da geht's
ja nicht nur darum dass man Empathie
braucht oder nicht natürlich brauchen
die Leute die da arbeiten Empathie aber
es geht vor allem um die
Arbeitsbedingungen die im Pflegebereich
herrschen wir haben Pflege Notstand wir
haben 100.000 Leute die zu wenig sind in
den Krankenhäusern in Deutschland in den
Kliniken und für die Patientinnen und
Patienten bedeutet das natürlich auch
ein zusätzliches Risiko und gleichzeitig
sind die Löhne miserabel die dort
gezahlt werden und da im übrigen tut die
Bundesregierung gerade herzlich wenig
obwohl sie den Reform vorgestellt habe
aber lauter machen uns jetzt den Einzeln
wir haben wir haben 1,8 Millionen offene
Stellen und jetzt sagt mir Herr Stegner
das hat nichts damit zu tun dass man
möglicherweise sich ganz sowohl für vom
Bürgergeld vom Sozialstation 600
Jugendliche allein im Verein und meine
lernstiftung die Jugendliche sagen das
heute klar und deutlich also bei mir
heißt die Überschrift des Trikot
schwitzt nicht von allein du musst schon
was machen wenn einer zu spät kommt muss
50 Liegestütze machen beim Steg bei der
anderen dürfen der kriegen die
wahrscheinlich ein Eis somit kannst du
die Leute Sozialstaat bekommen ja nice
ich glaube du hast auch die jungen junge
Leute damit mit versauen die brauchen
regeln ohne Regeln wird das nicht
funktionieren versuchen Sie meinen
Fußballspiel zu machen ohne Regeln aber
immer gespannt wer da gewinnt
wahrscheinlich ich in dem Kreis es macht
aber keinen Sinn nein nein
so dass die Leute die im Moment keine
Arbeit finden wir müssen den jungen
Leute sagen du musst was tun für dein
Leben
jungen Leuten eine Perspektive geben
ja sie lachen darüber herstellen Punkt
dass sie dass sie sie nehmen Luft raus
sie machen die Regeln nein nein gar
nicht gar nicht ich will nur dafür
sorgen und auch darauf hinweisen das ist
kein primäres Problem der Disziplin ist
die Leute sind diszipliniert es ist eine
Frage der Ausbildung wir haben gerade
über den Pflegesektor gearbeitet und es
braucht eine besondere Qualifikation
wenn man mit Patientinnen und Patienten
umgeht und die Leute über die Sie gerade
geredet haben die haben diese
Qualifikation nicht die muss ihnen
damit haben wir ein Fachkräfteproblem
und das muss überwunden das geht nur
über Ausbildung qualifiziert und
natürlich auch weil Disziplinen da haben
sie recht weißt du was die jungen Leute
zu mir sagen ich liege jetzt wirklich
nicht und ich bin ich schimpfe auch
nicht mit den Parteien überhaupt nicht
das bringt ja nichts ganz kurz die sagen
zu mir wenn das Bürgergeld kommt
überlege ich mir ob ich dann kündige das
sagen die Leute die 2400 € brutto
verdient und ich finde das ist
gefährlich also das ist nicht so wie
jetzt gerade der Kollege von der SPD
gesagt hat gegenseitiges aus die soll
man nicht machen wir müssen gucken dass
die Niedriglohnsektor besser bezahlt
werden und weniger besteuert werden ihr
müsst die Steuern senken und ihr könnt
ihr habt zum Beispiel schon Freund und
nach Europa
aber bitte macht was an den Steuern aber
da habe ich das Gefühl dass er da
beißerung habt ihr beißen
[Musik]